zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand
[Musique]
à l'aube ils combinent bonsoir et
bienvenue dans un europe sur radio
sensations en association avec tv 78 une
émission spéciale réalisée à berlin en
allemagne l'allemagne membre de l'union
européenne depuis 1958 membres de
l'espace schengen depuis 1995 et à
adopter l'euro le 1er janvier 1999 alors
dans cette émission nous vous emmènerons
à la découverte de la capitale
berlinoise et nous nous intéresserons
aux relations franco allemandes et puis
rester jusqu'à la fin de cette édition
car nous allons vous proposer un voyage
gastronomique zone europe avec le
soutien du fonds citoyen franco allemand
[Musique]
je serai
mais
[Musique]
soit
c
[Musique]
voici derrière moi l'un des symboles de
la ville de berlin la porte de
brandebourg elle a été construite au
xviiie siècle est devenu l'un des
symboles de la réunification des deux
allemagne après la chute du mur de
berlin en novembre 1989
sous drop
un peu de gastronomie à présent voici le
curry bourges c'est une spécialité
berlinoise une saucisse grillée ou
cuites à l'eau elle est servie entière
ou en rondelles accompagnées
généralement deux frites de sauce tomate
et naturellement de curry
soon europe / sensations alors je suis
aujourd'hui avec vincent garcia bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes le chef du
restaurant pastis ici à berlin comme la
boisson aromatisée à la liste qu'on
connaît beaucoup une boisson associé au
sud de la france c'est un petit rappel à
vos origines c'est ça absolument
donc j'ai grandi j'ai grandi pour la
plupart sur la côte d'azur et à aix en
provence
donc voilà après oui le pastis fait
partie de la boisson nationale de toute
façon chez nous en france tout court et
il n'y avait pas de nom qu'ils se soient
plus imposés que celui là c'était juste
lionax url diagnostiqué il ya eu
d'autres idées mais celui là c'est
vraiment imposé tout seul sans sens ça
c'est venu tout seul alors je le disais
on est ici à berlin est ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter comment est ce que
vous êtes venus ici vous installer à
berlin pour quelle raison et comment est
ce que votre façon peut-être de vivre au
jour le jour a changé
alors
je suis arrivé à berlin pour la première
fois en 1987 donc c'était avant la chute
du mur et c'était un pur hasard je
venais de finir mon service militaire je
suis arrivé à nice donc à cagnes sur mer
chez mes parents et mon père m'a mise
nice matin sur la table du petit
déjeuner le premier jour où il y avait
une annonce recherche cuisinier à berlin
j'ai appelé j'ai postulé j'ai eu le
poste je me suis en valeur envolé deux
jours plus tard pour berlin et j'ai
commencé à travailler tout de suite je
suis resté deux ans jusqu'en 1989 entre
temps j'avais des suds du mur oui avec
la chute du mur à l'époque j'avais
rencontré une berlinoise qui voulait
étudier en france donc nous sommes
repartis à aix-en-provence puisqu'elle
avait choisi la fac d'aix en provence
donc nous sommes retournés à aix en
provence en 1989 et puis nous y sommes
restés dix ans jusqu'en 1999
bon voilà
après dix ans à aix-en-provence donc ma
compagne berlinoise on avait assez du
sud elle en avait assez de mes copains
bruyant
fêtards et gastronomes et elle voulait
rentrer sur berlin puisqu'on venait
d'avoir un petit garçon et donc du coup
j'ai accepté effectivement de revenir à
berlin en 99
notre couple a pas tenu en 2000 on s'est
séparés voilà donc c'était pour
l'histoire et puis je décidé de rester à
berlin
puisque mon ex-compagne était avec mon
fils ici je me suis dit bon ben je vais
rester et je vais continuer mon aventure
ici et puis au fil des rencontres
j'ai monté plusieurs restaurants
certains avec succès d'autres avec
beaucoup moins de succès j'ai pris des
belles j'ai pris des belles gamelles
aussi parce que la gastronomie c'est pas
toujours
c'est pas toujours des succès il ya
aussi d un succès voilà et puis en 2009
j'ai trouvé ce local
qui s'est imposé comme le pastis et on a
réussi à en faire un établissement
sympathique qui marche très bien on est
très content et
ça a rien changé à ma façon de voir la
vie et la gastronomie puisque j'ai la
même philosophie - depuis quarante ans
que j'ai commencé ce métier j'ai la même
philosophie j'ai la même ligne de
conduite depuis 40 ans 40 ans vous
disiez vous avez vécu dans le sud de la
france vous avez des allées des allers
retours de façon plus ou moins régulière
est-ce que vous avez vu peut-être des
différences quand on va au restaurant en
france quand on va au restaurant en
allemagne les français les allemands le
terroir aussi peut-être qui est
différent alors complètement iliad est
de toute façon il y a des différences
même même au niveau régional chez nous
en france on a des différences de
partout bien entendu mais
là la gastronomie pour moi
la philosophie est tellement identique
pour tous les gastronomes qui la
pratiquent avec amour et avec passion
qu'il y a peu de il ya peu de différence
en fait la plupart des gastronomies
tiennent absolument à faire parler leur
terroir même à berlin alors que le
terroir est pauvre on essaye aussi de
faire parler le terroir de d'utiliser ce
que la nature nous offre c'est quoi par
exemple les spécialités du nord par
exemple les asperges voilà par exemple
asperges en saison des asperges on a on
a quelques on a un petit peu d'agneau
aussi de la queue un petit peu plus haut
dans le dans le brandenbourg on a on a
des élevages de buffle on a faim on a
réussi à mettre en place certains
produits après la spéciale la grande
spécialité on va dire à l'heure actuelle
celle asperges ça a toujours été
en saison et on essaye de mettre
certains produits comme les bourses
comme il ya des produits saisonniers
qu'on met en avant et qu'on travaille
c'est ça fait partie des choses
classiques ici et votre votre votre
cuisine ici vous vous souhaitez apporter
quoi par exemple à vos clients qu'elle
touche ne souhaitait pas nous on a
on a toujours utilisé
le petit côté exotique que nous offrons
en tant que français provençal on va
dire donc on offre une cuisine un petit
peu cheap et méditerranéennes provençal
revisiter un petit peu aussi bigarrée
avec avec les saisons et avec les
produits qu'on trouve ici donc aussi
avec des amis qui viennent
de pays lointains comme le japon et on
essaye de donner des parfois aussi des
petites touches asiatiques on essaye
voilà on se mélange
on est créatif très bien alors on va
passer en cuisine maintenant oui avec
votre équipe vous allez nous présenter
une de vos spécialités il s'agit alors
une autre spécialité c'est une recette
que j'ai à la carte depuis les années 90
à aix en provence c'est un médaillon de
lotte à la nîmoise juste légèrement
revisité un peu style bouillabaisse et
vous allez voir c'est une recette très
simple
et
phénoménalement très bien très bien on y
va on y va c'est parti alors c'est parti
je vais vous faire un petit taillerie
ville fait une petite rouille légèrement
légèrement safrané
les médaillons de lotte sont ici en cuir
poché dans la soupe de poissons que nous
avons préparés ici et le fenouil pour
rafraîchir un petit peu la recette c'est
un petit apport perso on va le cuisiner
légèrement croquant avec
le même principe de cuisson que pour la
lotte on va le pocher légèrement avec la
soupe de poisson voilà et ensuite on va
prendre le reste de cuisson de cette
soupe de poisson et on va détendre
l'aïoli et on va servir donc la recette
tiède c'est le but de cette recette ça
se mange tiennent
les médaillons de lotte posé sur un
croûton légèrement frotter avec de
l'aïoli frais et cette sauce détendue
par dessus c'est le principe même c'est
très simple c'est très bon et
c'est une de nos spécialités alors c'est
très simple on va faire un agneau du
donc on va prendre on va prendre
2 gousses d'ail
on va un chai finement voilà on va faire
un petit peu de sel
on va mettre un petit peu de scènes ça
ce sera un petit peu plus facile a lâché
voilà donc là on a travaillé avec des as
avec de l'ail sans germes c'est delahaye
relativement jeune il n'ya pas les gros
germes de dents ce qui fait qu'ils aient
moins d'amertume
moi je trouve que c'est plus sympa
voilà donc une fois que la ldh et on le
met dans sa préparation donc on va le
mettre
on y rajoute un petit peu de pommes de
terre
il rajoute un petit peu de toujours un
petit peu de piment d'espelette parce
que ça c'est
gégé quelques assaisonnement comme ça
sur lesquelles je ne fais aucune
concession le piment d'espelette jeu
j'en consomme
des kilos par an
et certains esprits ce qu'on a pour le
poisson aussi où une grande utilisation
aussi c'est des produits où je ne fais
pas concession monde dépensant sans
compter alors on va y rajouter un petit
peu
petit peu de poudre de safran pour la
couleur et un petit peu de moutarde
donc c'est une bonne base
et là on va monter un petit un petit
aïoli
donc on démarre avec une huile
classique où ils neutre
qui va permettre de la fixer qui va pas
lui donner trop d'amertume parce que
c'est pareil si on monte tout à l'huile
d'olive
le problème c'est que l'aïoli va être un
petit peu amer c'est dommage donc on va
essayer de le faire
moitié-moitié donc 50% avec huile neutre
voilà
bonus de tournesol
et on va là finira près tranquille
on
va finir à l'huile d'olive
on est pas mal
pointe d'acidité
[Musique]
quelques gouttes de jus de citron
voila
voila on allait au lycée près donc c'est
là si vous voulez ça c'est la base donc
c'est un simple un petit aïoli
légèrement safrané et on va s'en servir
pour faire la base de la sauce nîmoise
voilà donc ça on est bon
voilà donc c'est assez nos deux portions
de lot on va légèrement les assaisonner
avec un petit peu de piment d'espelette
légèrement du piment d'espelette
voilà
un petit peu de sel
où en affaires voilà légèrement la
région - et et assaisonner donc là on la
met de côté on voit la cuirasse suite
avec la soupe de poisson ça je vous fais
avoir tout de suite là on va préparer un
petit fenouil histoires de
on va prendre le fenouil on va le faire
suer tout doucement
et ensuite on va déglacer avec la soupe
de poisson et on va le finir
tranquillement pour qu'ils restent bien
croquants
il va finir de cuire
gentiment dans la soupe de poisson
donc là on va rajouter juste un petit
peu de mélange des pis
le sirop spice qui donne un petit peu de
piquant
petit peu de citron
[Musique]
donc la soupe de poisson
voilà le fenouil la cuisine il va se
préparer de préparer tranquillement
voilà tranquille ensuite on va prendre
une casserole tout bête alors nos
médaillons de lotte
voilà on va faire les croûtons shérif
voilà on va mettre les en-avants voir
couper quelques tranches de pain qu'on
va faire griller avec un petit peu
d'huile d'olive
[Musique]
un petit peu d'ail au four pour en faire
des petits croûtons sur lequel on va
déposer les médaillons de médaillons de
lotte voilà et là en fait
tout simplement poché dans la soupe de
poisson
tranquille
il y en a pour deux ou trois minutes
le fenouil il va se terminer doucement
aussi
voilà et ensuite on va vous préparer ça
vous allez voir c'est très très simple
et c'est juste excellent
on les retire
hao mettre trois couteaux
on va vous disposez
3 croûtons en hélice est en fait à la
base c'est quand même le poids du le
plat du pauvre on chez nous et donc là
on va les réchauffer
il est fait
dans la suite
voilà
on rajoute le bouillon de cuisson du
fellini faits par chèque
là on va voir a ajouté un petit peu de
fenouil croquant on va voulu rajouter
juste comme ça la voilà donc là
on y va
donc on dépose les petits morceaux de
l'autre con après pocher juste
voilà sur les croûtons
c'est la sauce nîmoise
donc en fait c'est la soupe de poissons
dans laquelle on a cuisiné le fenouil et
la lotte vas-y vas-y
la sauce nîmoise
on va découper un petit peu d'herbe pour
décorer
un petit peu de vert pour donner un
petit peu de juste pour donner un petit
peu de
ça pimente un petit peu voilà et ça
c'est une petite touche de couleur de
contraste voilà et ça c'est un plat
phare chez nous c'est juste un médaillon
de lotte à la nina la nîmoise avec bon
me présente sur croûtons
ça fait partie des grandes spécialités
de la maison voilà en direct bon appétit
soon europe
m
jennyfer dren et maintenant notre invité
dans un europe bonjour alors avant de
parler de votre parcours on va parler de
ce que vous faites ici à berlin vous
êtes originaire des yvelines et vous
faites une mobilité vous travaillez dans
une start up qui s'appelle benno sa
valeur elle valorise les produits locaux
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
peu plus déjà sur cette bien sûr alors
comme vous l'avait bien dit c'est une
start up qui a été fondée par deux
femmes francophones de belgique et de
france donc c'est dans un environnement
comme on pourrait dire
qui est très favorable en fait par l'un
est très favorable à tout ce qui est
produits locaux vegan et le rôle de
benno c'est de rendre accès et de
changer un peu le fou de système pour
permettre aux personnes d'avoir un peu à
l'instar dé l'eau fraîche un kit repas
qui permet avec une cote est de réaliser
nous cossette qui est végétarienne
local équidés locale qui dit forcément
moins d'impact sur la planète au niveau
de l'empreinte carbone
est également de saison donc si c'est
vraiment intéressant et également on
fait beaucoup d'efforts dans tout ce qui
est packaging et on a banni le plastique
très bien alors ce que vous pouvez nous
parler un peu de votre rôle au sein de
benno vous occupez de quoi alors je suis
community manager ou justement mon rôle
est de parler de benno et de à me
ramener en fait de montrer le point de
vue
un point de vue beaucoup plus
environnementale et écologique que peut
avoir en fait
à nos habitudes
dans notre alimentation alors les locaux
de benno il se trouve dans les locaux du
bouffay alors c'est au sud de berlin à
proximité d'un aéroport désaffecté s'est
assuré assez surprenant et bien pour
pour la première fois alors d'abord est
ce qu on s'y fait et est ce que le fait
d'être au sein de ses locaux ça permet
aussi de faire d'autres rencontres avec
d'autres gens de start up par exemple on
s'y fait très rapidement c'est un lieu
de travail comme un autre effectivement
on est plus amenés à croiser beaucoup de
monde ce qu'ils sont sur des projets
tout à fait différent notamment de
production de se développer
je dirais que oui puisque justement en
étendant start up on essaye de dynamiser
également le lieu
donc où ces événements pour l'instant
sur son sens tant sont en pause mais il
ya eu beaucoup d'événements de catering
donc voilà benno a été sollicité pour
organiser des événements et jouer un peu
le rôle d'un restaurateur ce qui permet
d'animer et en même temps de
sensibiliser les les personnes à la
cause de benno qui est d'avoir une
meilleure alimentation est moins
d'impact sur l'environnement et comme on
a évoqué mon rôle donc je gère les
réseaux sociaux et généralement c'est là
que que les gens se rassemblent alors
jennifer vous avez 23 ans vous gérez les
réseaux sociaux et la la le community
management de benno vous êtes issu d'une
formation commerciale marketing quel a
été votre parcours avant d'arriver à
bennoo en quelques mots alors mon
parcours après bac j'ai suivi une
formation comme vous l'avez cité
commerciale et marketing
qu'une une formation qui a été
essentiellement en alternance donc c'est
intéressant d'un point de vue
voilà déjà un pied dans le monde du
travail on connaît déjà les pratiques ce
qui se fait mais malheureusement peu
d'opportunités d'aller à l'étranger et
de voir d'autres façons de travailler
d'autres marchés d'autres habitudes
donc après mais mes trois ans d'études
avant de continuer finalement en master
j'ai décidé de partir au canada j'ai
obtenu un visa de travail mais
malheureusement avec loco évident ça n'a
pas abouti il jette arrive à berlin
exactement en fait c'est un projet
conjoint entre la maison de l'europe
divine et lamy local de ma ville qui m'a
permis au final de localiser ce ce
projet de mobilité à l'étranger alors le
plan et le plan canada au départ c'était
quoi c'était tout simplement de
travailler plus tôt dans la région du
québec pourquoi avoir un environnement
bilingue français et anglais et de
découvrir voilà deux un autre marché
d'autres façons travail comment est ce
que vous avez découvert benno ici à
berlin alors en fait
lorsqu'on est à la maison de l'europe
des vies non accompagnés et donc ils ont
un
réseau de contacts qui nous permet de
trouver en fait très facilement un stage
du benno et ça m'intéressait
particulièrement ne serait-ce qu'au
niveau de la mission mais aussi du du
but en fait de benno jeu m'a même jeu
végétarienne donc voilà on
prévient convaincu et on va dire ça donc
c'est beaucoup plus facile de travailler
déjà qu'on a à l'intérieur vous le
disiez vous avez été aidé par la maison
de l'europe des yvelines la mission
locale d'elancourt est-ce que avant de
venir ici en allemagne vous parliez déjà
allemand parce que finalement allé au
québec la langue française est quand
même un atout est-ce que vous parliez
déjà allemands avant d'arriver à berlin
oui tout à fait j'ai suivi mais j'ai eu
des études qui m'ont permis en fait de
pratiquer l'allemande puisque j'étais en
classe européenne mais c'est vrai
qu'après bac
il y avait beaucoup moins de pratique et
être en immersion c'est le meilleur
moyen de re parler une langue et je suis
vraiment très contente au final de
d'être venu à berlin depuis ce que ça me
permet de renouer avec la langue et
renouer aussi avec la culture merci
beaucoup et jenifer donne d'avoir été
avec mon plaisir dans une europe si on
veut sans en savoir plus sur benno il ya
un site internet bello benno point ces
eaux merci beaucoup merci
zone europe / sensations
[Musique]
au
revoir
j'ai cela en moi
[Musique]
tu es
tous
[Musique]
c
m
rob owen
[Musique]
je
et on finit cette édition spéciale de
zone europe depuis berlin depuis le
gendarme marque c'est un marché de noël
typiquement allemand j'espère que cette
émission vous a plu je remercie le fonds
citoyen franco allemand et la région
ile-de-france qui nous permettent de
réaliser cette émission n'oubliez pas
réagissez avec le hashtag jf à 2022 sur
les réseaux sociaux retrouver cette
émission en podcast audio et vidéo sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensations mais aussi sur tv 78 très
bonne soirée à vous et à la semaine
prochaine
sous drop
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile-de-france
zone europe avec le soutien du fonds
citoyen franco allemand